so for those of you who don't know we do
shoot this show on the same day that we
shoot another Thursday show because
we're in Australia we're a day ahead and
then I have one question for you I
haven't had a chance to catch up with
you in the last couple of hours did you
clean up all that confetti we should
probably just get started no seriously
did you click no I'm seriously did you
clean it up let's kick off this week
with some cool stuff TGS is happening at
the moment
and on Monday Sony announced war on Sony
Square Enix announced the Final Fantasy
9 is coming to ps4 and by coming we mean
it's on ps4 go get it right now yeah
it's at what is arguably apparently I
didn't play them the note the best Final
Fantasy game a lot of people think it's
the best Final Fantasy game is now you
can play it on your pants book came out
with PC last year and obviously came out
originally on the PlayStation 1 mm
really mm it's also discounted at the
moment sorry if you want to pick it up
you can do it on the tape no way and I
think it's definitely worth learning I
love playing old games I I only played
Final Fantasy 3 when it came out on beta
like when Vito was still a thing that
people played so it's very much worth
playing old games that you might have
never had the chance to play before and
so I definitely recommend this one so
there was a really big problem for some
very unlucky Rainbow six siege players
over the last week who installed the
latest update woman on ps4 and then
found that doing so corrupted their hard
drive yeah it seemed to be a problem
with inviting players to your party it
would cause the game to crash and then
even deleting Rainbow six siege and
reinitializing the system wouldn't fix
it so some people were up that
proverbial creek sans paddle but it's
been fixed by yourself now so if you've
been holding off getting involved in
blood orchid the latest update that
gives you three new operators in a theme
park map you can do it now on ps4 get
involved it's it's pretty cool yeah
everyone knows only Futuristics boy but
a PSA everything's okay now
you can play Chewie so this one's pretty
interesting the guys who made life life
is strange
forgot the name
we'll create a vampire RPG called
vampire with a wino I are a bumpier not
essential but it looks awesome so we saw
some gameplay a little while ago they
revealed an official trailer way back
when we first go look at it I bloody
love vampire game nor pun intended that
was terrible but uh yeah this one was
supposed to come out in November and
it's been pushed back so what happened
was the team we're getting stuck in a
technical blog which they've since fixed
but it did set them back a little while
yeah don't don't see Oscar Gilbert said
that he'd rather like take the time to
make sure I can polish the game and get
a quality product out rather than trying
to stick to an arbitrary date so it's
unfortunately it's been delayed from
November until spring 2018 yeah I mean
I'm personally really excited for this
one though it's not PG one love bloody
love them set in the slums of London
immediately following the end of willful
one that's pressed I was really
interesting I mean the trailer just
looks fascinating to me and going around
vampire being a good person or a bad
person
some wrapped up moral stuff in there it
uh yeah I'm really came for it and you
know a little bit more of a wait isn't
the best thing but hopefully they end up
making a bit again so that other famous
video game series you may know from
everyone's favorite movie critic Hideo
Kojima our zone of the enders is coming
to ps4 with zone of the enders the
second runner which is a ps4 version of
HD re-release of the ps3 version of zone
of the enders tube which was a ps2 game
however not only is it coming with 4k
support also coming with VR support yeah
so not only that it's coming to ps4 and
PC so it looks like it's VR mode which
is called zone of the enders Anubis mas
will be supporting VR across both the
PlayStation console and whatever BR
you've got on your computer Oh oscillate
from computer the trailer is really cool
you can see sitting in the cockpit of
one of the giant robots which was super
super cool having played a lot of VR
games that are you inside the cockpit of
a giant robot though I get motion
sequels very quickly so you maybe just
like think about that before you jump in
deserted vienna's me I thought motion
ckv well maybe you weren't but uh you
can find out for yourself because it's
out in the spring of next year so this
one is kind of
old news so we won't dig into all the
nitty-gritty of what happened but
basically as a result of a pity pie
video there's been some review bombing
of fire watch on Steam if you don't know
what review bombing is it's from people
who disagree with something the
developers have done that doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with the
game but people will give it a bunch of
low scores that results in it having a
lower mean score on Steam or whatever
else because they simply don't like the
developer don't do that for starters so
what's themes done is they've introduced
the review histogram it'll show you a
history of all the reviews that a game
has received over the life over its
lifetime and you can click on certain
points where it might be overly negative
and see a sampling of those reviews so
you can make more of an informed choice
about seeing if something did get
reviewed on they also said that most
games that have been reviewed bombed end
up going back to where they were before
the review buying so something like fire
what goes on which was on a generally
positive rating he's now on a mixed
they're saying that it'll probably go
back to a mostly positive rating but
review bombing is just it's just a silly
thing to do
I mean I think it doesn't really matter
what side you're on I think it's just
sort of unhelpful I mean an entire point
of reviews is to find out whether or not
you're gonna enjoy a game absolutely and
whether or not you know it's gonna be up
your alley when you read reviews you're
looking for you know helpful input as to
how it plays or how it looks or anything
like that and review bombs that don't
have anything to do with that I can know
that goes the problem that is everything
we have for you this week to let us know
what you cared about and what you'll be
playing this weekend down in that
comment section and we will see you
again on Monday seriously did you clean
it up long ago dude why are we coming
that out seriously did you no I did not
you [ __ ] serious it's so epic